Armed with our list of 1 million SNVs, we're
ready to compare genomes all over the world. Now, for
example, we can take this genome of person 1.
And we can go SNV by SNV, and match them
to the SNVs that we find in the genome
of person 2. For example, let's say we look at
an SNV on chromosome three, I've marked the location of
the SNV here in red, in the genomes of person
1 and person 2. For example, person 1 may
have two alleles for SNV one just like person 2.
Because person 1 and person 2 are identical at
the site, we give them a score of 1. Now
let's take a look at a different SNV on
chromosome seven, here I've marked it on the actual chromosome
seven for person 1 and person 2. Now, for
the second SNV, person 1 is homozygous for the C
allele, but person two is heterozygous, with a C and a G allele. So they would
be assigned a matching score of 0.5. Right?
It's a half match. Out of the two possible
letters that they could match, only the C's
match. And now let's look at this last
SNV. SNV three here, on chromosome 16. In
this case, person 1 is homozygous T for SNV
three, but person 2 is homozygous G. There is
no match at all. So the matching score in
this case would be 0. So in each case,
we can look at each individual SNV, and make
a comparison from Person 1 to Person 2 and
assign a score, of either 1, 0.5, or 0.
Or we could look at multiple SNVs at once
and take the average. The average here, we had 1
plus 0.5 plus 0 is 1.5 divided by 3 is 0.5. Our overall matching
score for all three SNVs together is half. This means that between person 1 and
person 2 for these SNV's, half of the alleles they have match. This matching
score is also referred to as an IBS score, or an identity by state score.
Identity by state is just the coincidental possession
of alleles that appear identical. It's your identity
by an individual state, or SNV. We can also write this score from 0 to 1
as a 0% to 100%. Where 100% is a perfect match, 50% is a half match, and 0%
is no match at all. So let's take an individual that has an allele composition
for four SNV's like this. The first SNV is CC. The second one
is TG. The third one is AG. And the fourth one is AA. Which
of the following options would this individual share an IBS score of 50%, on
average for all four SNV's? Be sure to check any and all that apply.